good morning it gets tuesday so on
Friday afternoon US President Donald
Trump signed an executive order that
reshapes u.s. immigration law and
there's been a lot of confusion about it
even within the government about who's
affected by this law and precisely what
it means so I thought today I'd take a
closer look at what the executive order
actually says so first the order bans
for a period of 90 days all immigrant
and non-immigrant entry into the United
States from all citizens of seven
nations Iran Iraq Libya Somalia Sudan
and Yemen these seven nations seem to
have been chosen because they were cited
in 2015 and 2016 laws signed by
President Obama that required residents
of those countries to get a visa to
visit the United States that the
executive order states that they can't
enter the United States even with a visa
although there are a few exceptions for
diplomats so what does this mean well
for an Iranian professor at Yale it
means that if she leaves the US she
won't be allowed to re-enter it even
though she's a well known opponent of
the Iranian regime and for a doctor who
was abroad battling a polio outbreak it
meant being denied entry into the u.s.
despite his visa to be here now I know
those probably sound like particular
examples of hard luck stories but
because people from those countries
already needed visas with specific
reasons to visit the United States like
visiting family or studying or working
in a specialized field almost all the
stories are hard-luck stories the
executive order initially also seemed to
apply to legal permanent residents of
the United States who aren't citizens
so-called green card holders although
the language in the order is extremely
hard to parse like even to those within
the government I mean at one point on
Sunday Trump's chief of staff said the
order does not apply to green card
holders and then later in the very same
interview said of course it does apply
to green card holders but after much
confusion and emergency lawsuits it now
appears that permanent residents will
not be subject to the ban it's also
unclear from the language in the order
whether it applies to dual citizens like
if you're a Canadian citizen who was
born in Somalia as Canada's immigration
minister is there's still some confusion
as to whether you can enter the u.s. now
critics of this part of the executive
order and I should acknowledge that I am
among them argued that it is really
poorly targeted I mean no foreign
nationals from any of those seven
countries has killed even a single
American in a terrorist attack ever in
general terrorism in the US since 9/11
has been
exceedingly rare like in the past decade
American civilians are literally more
likely to die by lightning strike than
terrorism and notably most of the
attacks that do happen in the US are
carried out by American citizens or
permanent residents and those attacks
wouldn't be prevented by the order now
the counter-argument is that there may
be threats from these seven countries we
don't know about but it's really hard to
prove a negative like it's hard for me
to prove that I'm not a terrorist
because how can you be sure I'm not just
for the record in case big brother is
watching I'm not in case Big Brother
Dead big brother is definitely watching
anyway all this is my concerns about the
band don't really follow along
traditional left-right lines like the
very conservative Cato Institute for
instance said there is little national
security benefit to Trump's executive
order on immigration and many although
by no means all Republican Congress
people and senators agree John McCain
and Lindsey Graham for instance released
a statement saying that the ban may be
remembered as a self-inflicted wound in
the fight against terrorism and then
there is the second part of the
executive order which affects admission
of refugees into the United States so
back in 2011 the Obama administration
dramatically slowed the process of
refugee applications from Iraq for six
months and off cited precedent for what
Trump announced on Friday but this is
very different Trump is suspending all
refugee admission to the United States
from all countries for 120 days and
suspending all refugee resettlement from
Syria indefinitely this appears to
include people who've already been
vetted approved and received visas which
is also very different from what
happened in 2011 sidenote you may have
heard that there is no vetting of Syrian
refugees coming into the United States
that is simply not true as discussed in
this video the process includes a huge
variety of background checks and
interviews and often takes more than two
years the executive order also
prioritizes quote refugee claims made by
individuals on the basis of religious
based persecution which Trump has said
will mean prioritizing Christian
refugees when the program restarts
although that's not actually stated in
the order and it's not clear it would be
legal for context though last year the
u.s. accepted about 39,000 Muslim
refugees about 37,000 500 Christian ones
and also 8,500 people of other or no
faith but just to be absolutely clear
Muslim refugees who have been vetted and
approved for admission to the United
States cannot currently get in but
either can Christian or Buddhist
refugees for at least 120 days Norton
interpreters who served with the
American armed forces in Iraq because no
refugees are being allowed into the
United States and this blanket ban also
seems to me very poorly targeted for one
thing it lumps all refugees together
whether they're from Syria or South
Sudan or Burma like most refugees
resettled in the United States in 2015
were not Syrian they were Burmese but
also many Syrian refugees are victims of
Isis who can speak firsthand about its
horrors and that is a moderating force
not a radicalizing one imagining Syrians
monolithically is as dangerously
simplistic as imagining that ending
refugee resettlement will solve the u.s.
as security challenges I shared John
McCain's feeling that ultimately this
kind of blanket ban will do more to help
terrorist recruitment than improve our
security now Trump counters that it will
make us more safe and he certainly has
access to top-secret information that I
don't have access to but given that
these policies wouldn't have prevented a
single u.s. terror fatality from the
last 40 years it's hard to see exactly
how we're safer there are also other
issues of legal confusion in the order
for instance the order states quote the
United States cannot and should not
admit those who do not support the
Constitution but as many law professors
have pointed out that's kind of
ludicrous I mean according to that
sentence if you are for instance
Canadian and you support a parliamentary
system of government over the system
outlined in the US Constitution are you
no longer legally allowed to visit
Disney World because that does appear
now to be the law also when foreigners
attempt to enter the United States as in
most countries they have the right to
seek asylum and be interviewed by an
immigration officer to determine if the
asylum seeker has a credible fear of
persecution but the executive order
explicitly states that no benefits will
be extended to citizens of the affected
nations when they attempt to enter the
United States and such an interview
would probably constitute a benefit so
as of now it does not appear that people
are being allowed to seek asylum which
is in violation of an existing US law
called the Immigration and Nationality
Act which an executive order cannot
legally override in short no matter how
you feel about immigration this
executive order is a hot mess it is too
ambiguous self-contradictory and unclear
to be effective law now I want to
emphasize that much of this may be moot
in
for months as parts of the order expire
but even if that occurs I worry we've
already made a dangerous statement that
the u.s. won't do its part in the
refugee crisis and that we will
discriminate based solely on place of
birth I think those are mistakes that
imagining a diverse group of over a
hundred million people to be some
terrifying and singular other only
encourages others to imagine us that way
it's hard to imagine people complexly
especially when you're being told to
fear them but I've found it helpful to
listen so I've put together a playlist
of refugees telling their stories I'd
ask you to listen to them to believe
them and to see them as people instead
of merely as threats tank I'll see you
on Friday